what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have a lot of new Deadpool 3 News
to go over including some new promos and
a new picture from the set also some
pretty significant plot details to go
over as well and we're going to talk
about when to expect that first trailer
now first things first some of you might
have seen that leaked look at
Wolverine's official cow his mask and it
is very very comic accurate and we have
a new promo here for Deadpool 3 coming
out before the trailer and this is a
great sign that the trailer is indeed
coming soon and if you've been keeping
up on the news you know that we are
actually less than a month away from
getting the Deadpool 3 teaser trailer
most likely and again these promos
coming out are a great sign because once
the trailer is released full promo for
the film can officially begin and as you
can see in this new promo that we have
here it looks epic we have Deadpool
Wolverine full comic accurate costume
here this is designed by Marvel Studios
so we can tell that everything right
here is going to be how it is going to
be in the film so you are looking at
Wolverine and Deadpool how they will
look in Deadpool 3 right here so for
those who are wondering this is what
he'll look like and he is indeed very
very comic accurate which we love to see
except for his height but what can you
do now before it really looked like we
were going to get a storyline of
Deadpool kills the fox universe but it
looked like the reverse of that might
actually be true Deadpool might actually
be trying to save the fox Universe let
me explain what I mean by that according
to The Insider can we get some toast
they State the Deadpool 3 synopsis
shared with subscribers is not a joke
synopsis like many think it's absolutely
relevant to the plot of the movie and
they shared a photo of Wade Wilson as a
used car salesman now here's the
synopsis that was shared before after
facing some professional setbacks while
going through a midlife crisis Wade
Wilson decides to officially retire
Deadpool and becomes a used car salesman
but when his friends family and the
whole world are at stake Deadpool
decides to bring his katanas out of
retirement he recruits an unwilling and
wary Wolverine to not only fight for
their survival But ultimately their
legacy so some people have I think
really really missed the point of this
synopsis and the point of the synopsis
is that the Multiverse is beginning to
be destroyed it's beginning to CR um and
now his universe is at stake so in order
to protect his friends and his family he
needs to step up as Deadpool once again
teaming up with Wolverine to try and
save the fox Universe this is where the
multiversal traveling begins and what's
really interesting about this is that
Deadpool can break the fourth wall so he
can kind of know what is happening
without anybody else really having any
clue in fact I wouldn't be surprised if
he made a joke about the MCU trying to
basically move on from the fox Universe
when all this starts happening he could
make a joke stating something like oh no
the MCU is trying to get rid of the old
universes where Marvel characters exist
we have to stop this or we have to go
join the MCU how can we do this well let
me go get my old buddy Hugh Jackman out
of retirement and go find Wolverine in
one of these universes and try to stop
it hopefully we'll learn a little bit
about the film in the teaser trailer and
we already know quite a little bit about
the film about what the plot is going to
be about what is going to happen during
it but hopefully the teaser sheds some
light and like I mentioned we can expect
that teaser trailer pretty soon at the
Super Bowl now it's important to note
that although this is speculated and
reported by a lot of different people
it's still just a rumor right now and
it's not officially confirmed yet
however many people do believe that is
when it's coming and it does make a ton
of sense for them to release the trailer
during the Super Bowl that way millions
of people can watch it I've made this
point before but there are millions of
people out there who know about Deadpool
and Wolverine separately but also
combined at the same time but here's the
deal I am specifically talking about
people who aren't super hardcore Marvel
MCU fans like you and I you and I we
talk about this every day we watch
videos about it every day keep up to
date with the news the general populace
is not like that however Deadpool is
such a popular character that even
people who don't even have any interest
in Marvel went and watched Deadpool 1
and Deadpool 2 and are very interested
in another dead film on top of that they
are insanely interested in Wolverine
because he is one of the most iconic
superheroes both in the comics and in
the movies of all time so premiering the
teaser trailer at the Super Bowl showing
the entire world hey look we are doing
another Deadpool movie and Wolverine
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine is going to be
a part of it that's going to get
everybody talking about it I mean it's
going to be absolutely insane so it
makes perfect sense for them to do it at
the Super Bowl it makes business sense
and it honestly is in very Ryan Reynolds
fashion to do it at a sporting event I'm
actually kind of concerned that the
teaser is only going to be the two of
them talking simply announcing a movie
which they've kind of already done but
hopefully we get some really great
footage and like I mentioned we do have
some new set photos to go over we'll
talk about those and show them in just a
bit but first big thank you to Avatar
braving the elements for sponsoring this
video I know many of you love the
breakdowns that we do Easter egg videos
reactions and reviews on this channel
which is why I think you will love
Avatar braving the elements the official
Companion podcast for avatar The Last
Airbender now I personally love
companion podcasts that go with whatever
I'm watching at the time because I feel
like you just get so much more
information that you wouldn't get from
anywhere else which is why I am so
excited for Avatar braving the elements
each week hosts Janet vanney the voice
of Kora and Dante Bosco the voice of
Zuko rewatch every episode of The Last
Airbender they're joined by special
guests like the cast super fans and even
the creators of the show Michael De
Martino and Brian Kitco for a deep dive
and a behind the-scenes look into the
Avatar verse that you can't get anywhere
else so listen to Avatar braving the
elements wherever you get your podcast
so here we have a new look at Deadpool
and Wolverine on the set of Deadpool 3
and I swear every time we get a look at
Deadpool 3 it is just absolutely amazing
to see Deadpool and Wolverine standing
next to each other Hugh Jackman and Ryan
Reynolds it's epic so here's a brand new
look and I will say this they did show a
photo of a Deadpool variant but since
Ryan Reynolds has asked everybody to
really not share spoilers I'm not going
to put them on the channel however if
you just want to search them in Google
they're very easy to find just do a
quick search Deadpool 3 Deadpool variant
Wade Wilson variant and they'll pop up
and we already knew that there were
going to be Deadpool variants I mean
Deadpool 3 is very much a very big
Multiverse film in fact Deadpool 3 is
really when everything is going to go
down we are going to start to see the
Multiverse kind of collapse like I
mentioned with the beginning synopsis
and Deadpool and Wolverine are going to
travel to different universes and
they're going to see firsthand showing
us firsthand what exactly is happening
and that's just one of the many things
that makes Deadpool just extremely
exciting then of course as we've been
talking about for the while the TVA is
going to play a pretty significant role
in Deadpool 3 as well if the reports are
true the TVA is going to start Gathering
different heroes from these different
universes that are collapsing and saving
them so they can join a huge multiversal
Avengers team and prepare for a fight
against King the Conqueror against the
Council of kings and all of their
variants that follow them and according
to insiders Deadpool and Wolverine are
not done after Deadpool 3 but in fact
are actually going to be a couple of the
leaders leading this new big multiversal
Avengers team in Avengers Secret Wars in
fact many different insiders are pretty
adamant that Wolverine is going to be
kind of the leader alongside other OG
characters like Toby Maguire Spider-Man
in Avengers Secret Wars so I know we
cannot wait to see that I know it's
getting super exciting hopefully we get
the trailer during the Super Bowl but in
the meantime let me know your thoughts
about these new photos these new Promos
in the comments down below please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you are automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof